the discovery of the tomb of the
egyptian king tutankhamun 100 years ago
this year made headlines around the
world and made celebrities of the
british archaeological team involved but
a new exhibition at oxford university is
shining a new light on the other workers
on that dig that history had forgotten
roxanna saberi has the story
unearthed in egypt a century ago tootin
commons tomb instantly became one of the
greatest finds in archaeology a
nineteen-year-old king buried in a
chamber left largely undisturbed for
over three thousand years british
excavator howard carter basked in the
splendor of its discovery an english
archaeological expedition headed by a
man named howard carter sought to
uncover the tomb of an ancient egyptian
pharaoh king tut ankman
in the decades since the treasures have
glittered across the globe over one
million six hundred thousand people had
queued and seen the exhibition while
tutankhamun has taken his place in
popular culture
[Music]
but these portrayals says renowned
egyptologist richard parkinson hide the
realities of history the press interest
of course and the discovery and all the
popular interest has turned it into this
sort of cultural stereotype tell me
about that stereotype it's the indiana
jones one it's the downton abbey school
of archaeology he hopes this new exhibit
at oxford university challenges those
views by highlighting the people of
egypt
parkinson says dozens of egyptians
helped carter but most remain unnamed
and uncredited what does history tell us
about the egyptian members of carter's
team not enough
the archive of course is a british
archive
it's
compiled in a colonious period
delving into carter's archives stored at
the university parkinson picked out
pieces like these photos of a boy posing
in a necklace from the casket it's where
the jewelry belongs on the necks of an
egyptian teenager
the problem is we don't know his name
why is his name not known
because he was simply a mannequin
other images show egyptians unsealing
doorways conducting the post-mortem and
carrying crates they were very skilled
but they didn't have say the university
education that we would expect of an
archaeologist these days and because
they couldn't tell their own story they
remained anonymous they have remained
anonymous
carter did thank his four egyptian
foremen but even today curators can't
match their names with their faces ahmed
gerigar is the best known somewhere in
these photographs we will have his face
but we cannot from the archive identify
which man he is
in egypt professor hen mohammed abdel
rahman says she's identified 11 other
egyptian team members i found their
descendants and that carter actually
kept a record of everyone's name but
somehow it was lost so you're hopeful
that one day these egyptians will get
their credit yes of course of course and
i believe they will do this one day back
at oxford parkinson hopes these glimpses
into the past will inspire others to
fill in the blanks of history i think we
have not heard the end of the tomb of
tutankhamen for cbs saturday morning
roxanna suberi oxford england
i remember visiting the exhibit you know
in los angeles it come from so far away
but i mean it just
heightens this notion that these these
men
of the colonial era or post-colonial
area were the one
that made all of these discoveries and
there's so many other people involved
who had the expertise because they knew
they knew the history and the lore and
where to look and it's nice to see the
stories uncovered now especially with
this you hope that time hasn't done away
with the ability to actually uncover and
know who they are as you said we've not
heard the end of the story i like that i
like that